yo what's up guys prestige here and I'm
with a guy named striker hey what's up
guys and so we're gonna be playing some
minigame striker is another youtuber and
he contacted me he had this he has this
group of youtubers going it's confers a
big community so we're playing a little
mineplex mini-games yeah room hub that
man looks calm place for dragging this
good yeah so maybe you guys know what it
is is my first time of playing it
apparently it's parkour with a dragon
chasing you yeah so this will be a fun
run the dragons on like a fixed pattern
so you just have to keep on going you
see that yeah I see him okay oh ok so
we're going that way yep can people hit
you know looking at you ok oh I don't
know why the axe is there oh it's there
oh this is really difficult with
everyone in your like in your face oh
yeah there it is yeah well I fell
alright well now you guys get to see the
visual everyone else trying to escape
from the tracking and many people
falling into lava I'm still doing it
right oh that's not good ok come on ok
and your dragons this is ok that's not
good ok I'm not oh look out look out ok
I also loved oh ok optical hide ok well
there goes strikers now let's see if
anybody else is still love ok tundra
kill the heck where are these guys they
got far this is the right way yeah
that's the right way all right I just
thought jumping it's got screwed this is
a Tundra kill boy is going pretty pretty
hard in the projects yeah he's doing
pretty good
dragon is flapping its wings really hard
and did he oh I thought he just like
killed himself and I'm like oh no
there's a little little thing down there
is little pet oh my gosh that's pretty
good every oh okay um this is there's
another guy from the group hello I'm
prestige I'm DJ hi all right and I was
that I guess I notice how that was
pretty it was pretty short but uh you
know I'll just record another round I
guess two are we gonna stand alavi or
you next one will start in like 30
seconds or a minute okay so i might just
cut that out in terms of the time
because it's just us sitting in a lobby
but yeah she just got to boil it oh ok
was he a saint guy those before no the
different guy okay so like there are so
these things the disruptor and the war /
I'm assuming the disruptor can mess with
people but placing TNT not too sure
honestly um this war / thing is an ultra
kit it looks like you get into France
yeah i'm assuming he can just tell
support yeah ultra is like a donator kit
okay and this disruptor kit uh I think
you just I think you play seeing tea or
something all right i don't i don't
really know I feel like even if i had
the war per hour just died because i
like I just throw the inter pearl like
at something and it would just go above
or below and i just sent me in lava i
can buy disruptor I'm doing it right now
okay all right I'm going to kill you
don't give it nice thank you i'll try to
kill somebody oh okay Matt go Matt nice
we still recording yeah yeah
let's go all the people oh gosh okay oh
crap i dig up over that crap crap nope
okay we good all right now I can do the
parkour map without everyone in my face
whoa whoa whoa whoa oh gosh and no you
had to like do epic jumps right there oh
ok we get up oh ok ok I can still I can
still go go go ok let's go vertical
scale Oh 10 I failed that back off
dragon are we going here go here Oh Oh
No if you get to the pyramid you gotta
go email backside off out there it is
yep dragon killed me I missed a jump
than I thought I could get by with using
another chump but that failed so what do
you do at the pyramid all you have to
just go around it and then in the back
yeah okay the first time I plated I just
like SAT there on the pyramid like do I
just sit here and die is that how I win
this there's like no obvious way to get
through it and I think I see that the
goal you're trying to get at ok Oh
million i look out as a dragon yeah I
know ok uh-huh cute what what do you say
thank you Oh a good good good disruptor
kit yeah that was great oh this guy's
better win all this to a guy la oh I
think I saw him jump off the edge ok
well didn't even know the guy still
alive all right then then guys I hope
you enjoyed these two this two little
plays of of what's called dragon escape
yeah dragon the dragon escape i think
i'll enter they're probably i guess i'll
just be posting more of this later since
i didn't know this server existent and
also a quick note in this i want to
thank you guys for 500 subs it means a
lot and i will be doing an entire series
as a thank you and be on the lookout for
that arges peace out